[Music]
hey you guys
look i made a little intro video yeah
hopefully hopefully there was sound on
it i don't know if it was if there was
or not
but i don't know when i saw it oh okay
there was no i mean when you showed it
to me
oh well yeah but that's not a speaker on
so i can't tell that wasn't on the
stream i wasn't sure
but it's got like little music on it
yeah nico says
any word on the cookbook i haven't been
active on the videos for a bit i'm
actually on the very last section
so all i have to do is do one more short
section and then we're going to do a
quick um
photo shoot because i need some pictures
of him like in his chef jacket and stuff
that i want to like insert in there and
then
it should be done and then we're going
to put some of the cat in there too
the other thing is i want to also go
over and proofread make sure not
proofread but just make sure that
everything is easy to read and use
you know what though i was thinking yeah
maybe i shouldn't get into something
like that i was thinking about maybe
putting a section
at the beginning about [ __ ] like knife
skills and preparation but well you
could put that in the introduction
because i have space for an introduction
we haven't written that yet
okay yeah because um
people need to you know although you
know that that's that's on the
individual cook whether or not they want
to learn how to develop
knife skills and you can go online to
see how to learn that
stuff like how to yes i mean don't feel
like you have to put every single thing
in this book like i said it's kind of
it's kind of like our take on stuff
recipes we make all the time
recipes we grew up with yeah stuff like
that and so you know kind of specific to
us
yeah i want a big part a big part of
cooking
is physicality physical skills
regular kitchen skills and it really
pains me sometimes to see a home cook
struggle with tools or to do things out
of order
like not picking a pot up and moving it
in a certain way you know what i mean to
pour
there's just weird weird things that
non-cooks
do that drive professional cooks up the
[ __ ] wall
yeah like no no no that's not how you
hold a knife
that kind of [ __ ] stop it stop it yeah
you're going to cut your [ __ ] fingers
off you know and it's just
[ __ ] that they do you know but that's on
the cook i'm just going to leave that
mostly on the cake yeah you can you
can't take responsibility for everybody
cutting their fingers off
right and that's a subject unto itself
how to develop all those skills yeah and
if you're a grown person and you don't
have those skills yet and
there's a problem that usually means
that you're not cooking enough and
uh you may not be interested in this
cookbook i don't know
depends i don't know how normal people
operate really
i do what i do i don't really know what
y'all do yeah
i do what i want yeah i do what i want
yeah i was made to do that
[ __ ] because i grew up in [ __ ]
kitchens
you know when i was in high school in in
michigan
i was working at [ __ ] um at a bar and
grill down there and the grill was
fantastic
and the two cooks that worked in there
were like little gordon ramsay
[ __ ] they were mean
a little gordon ramsay yeah no they were
young you know they were they were
actually
they were actually guys in their 20s and
30s but from my point of view they were
older guys
you know what i mean yeah and they made
good money and they were really good at
what they were doing i didn't realize
it wasn't until later when cooking
became real corporate where they're
buying [ __ ] from [ __ ] cisco and [ __ ]
pre-made and everything
you know that corporate is that [ __ ]
they're not cooking
yeah they're just heating stuff yeah
heating [ __ ] up ree you know
started off watching washing dishes and
then a couple months later i'm in there
making salad dressings we made salad
dressings from [ __ ] scratch
and then making desserts [ __ ]
custards and then [ __ ]
uh being the pastries and pastries and
bread and then you start graduating
up to dealing with [ __ ] deep fryers
and you know and
so you had to work your way up from the
bottom and i learned
real essential skills that were real old
school
you know what i mean yeah you don't just
and it makes a big difference
it makes a big difference in what comes
up like a store-bought
salad dressing just doesn't like say for
a store-bought blue cheese
that just never like from craft that'll
never compare to [ __ ]
scratch made blue cheese dressing yeah
and that's the thing it's like sometimes
it's okay it's good enough
yeah it's fine and easy but that's yeah
and well the thing about it is like it's
not even so much that
because it has to be shelf stable so it
has to have like a lot of stuff in it
that keeps it from
you know going bad too fast or whatever
so it's like there's stuff in there that
if you made it fresh it wouldn't be in
there so yeah
all those stuff like blue cheese and
ranch and [ __ ] like that
it's a it's it's a specific ratio of
sour cream and mayonnaise
and then it's seasoned and then you're
adding [ __ ] like crumble blue cheese
into it
and there's just nothing pre-made that's
ever gonna [ __ ] compare with that
it's thick it's cool it's real cool
and cold when it comes out of there it's
almost kind of like
cheese flavored [ __ ] ice cream that's
how rich and creamy that [ __ ] is
it's just cheese flavor yeah man that's
good there's nothing
nothing like the real like it sounds
gross but also kind of good
well when it goes on the salad you know
depending on what kind of lettuce and
everything
it's just the texture of it is just you
know nothing out of a damn bottle is
going to compare with it
yeah just doesn't happen nope so um
let's see what everybody's saying
yeah that's why we because here's the
thing like i said we're still going to
do matinee shows but we can't because
last night i was like well do you want
to watch a new movie and talk about that
tomorrow do you want to talk about more
food
and he was like well i'm kind of tired i
don't really feel like watching a couple
movies so
he's like well we'll just talk about
pizza tomorrow now we didn't actually
make pizza today
today we made brisket yeah it made
brisket well actually last night because
yeah he put it on and let it cook
all night and yeah i couldn't do it for
12 hours yeah it cooked for as well big
old brisket
it just like felt like butter yeah fell
apart you didn't even need
to we were trying to eat it with a knife
i said [ __ ] you don't even need the
knife you can just pull it apart with a
wooden port
and it's yeah it was delicious yeah i
got a big old beef brisket
yes it's a slab
slathered it with well first of all i
took gravy master i would have taken
liquid smoke but i didn't have any
took gravy master and [ __ ] put it in
and brushed it on there
on the outside of it let it sit for a
bit
and then i slathered the whole thing
with uh
french's french's um
uh mustard and then put a bunch of
cracked black pepper over it
and just let it sit in there and then
cooked it then put it in it put it in a
pan covered it with uh
tin foil cooked at 12 hours at 220
degrees
it came out real good yeah you put it on
like nine o'clock last night you took it
out a little before
that just fell off of the outside of it
because it's it was kind of a fat you
know brisket is kind of fatty but then
what was left is that
real nice that'll make some good
sandwiches you got to clean it the right
way yeah you got to cut the right way
it's just like roast beef you know
yeah tila is asking favorite pizza
toppings
oh man a lot of them
[Laughter]
fresh mushroom yeah pineapple and ham
uh there was a barbecue way of doing
barbecue pizza hadn't done a long time
ago
got to go back and look at it it's like
a barbecue meat lover's pizza there's a
way to do that but that none of that
[ __ ] traditional
that's all [ __ ] we came up with here
um italian type toppings are really
i honestly i like sun-dried tomatoes on
mine i like i don't like a lot of
meats if it you know what when i was
growing up my favorite pizza when i'm
growing up and if i can still find it
sometimes
um we had this tiny little hole in the
wall pizza joint
uh near where we grew up in daytona and
with you know when i was a kid they
didn't have delivery really
so you had to go and pick it up and uh
the [ __ ] was the name of that place
pantheon
i don't even know if it's still there
but um they did
a fantastic hamburger and onion
pizza and it wasn't like spicy sausage
like italian sausage or anything like
that was just like hamburger with a
little bit of
like maybe salt and pepper or whatever
so it wasn't like real spicy meat
but so it was like hamburger with like
you know onions on it like sauteed
onions and that [ __ ] was delicious
but other than that i'm not a big fan of
i'll eat meat on pizza you know i'm not
picky i'll eat pretty much anything on
pizza but
if i'm you know left to my own devices
um
i like i tend to like more vegetable i
like mushrooms i like
peppers sun-dried tomatoes roma tomatoes
banana peppers that kind of stuff like i
like all that kind of stuff on pizza
okay we're going to talk about pizza
yeah let's talk about some [ __ ] pizza
i um
have a section in the cookbook about
pizza
pizza has rules all right pizza has
rules if you break any of these rules
you're gonna [ __ ] that pizza up
okay where i'm gonna start
first rule of pizza is that making your
own dough is the key if you go down
there and buy a pre-made piece
i mean i've done that kind of [ __ ]
you're trying to make make something
real fast out of nothing you know what i
mean
i've i've taken you got to have a pizza
stone that's the first
thing here's the first rule it's a good
piece you must have
a stone pizza stones can be
had in different ways they'll sell it as
a pizza stone it's round
there are also certain kinds of tiles
that you can get
there are stone tiles from people put
them in floors
and if you cut them the right size you
can actually line an entire oven
rack with a stone but
you got to know what you're doing you
got to have good peel skills all right
so you need a stone
pizza cooks by induction all right in
other words
you have a hot surface and you place a
cold pizza a cold
dough on top of it and the
heat from the stone is sucked directly
into that dough making it
crispy and chewy if the temperature is
wrong the texture will be [ __ ]
up you must cook at at least
500 degrees the best is about 550 to 600
but some ovens don't go up that high
ours only goes to 525
yeah some some of the best pizzas are
cooked in [ __ ] ex
kilns where they used to fire like
porcelain stuff
so they can get close to like seven or
eight hundred degrees
as the cooking as the as the cooking
temperature goes up the cooking time
goes down
so at 550 degrees on a hot stone
cooking time on a thick on a pizza
that's fully loaded with stuff
about 15 minutes between 12 and 15
minutes
if it's 7 800 degrees it might only be
five minutes but you get a feel for it
yourself
most so when you're making a pizza most
of the cooking time is trying to heat
that stone up
so that stone might be in that oven for
an hour before it gets up to 550 degrees
but you're only going to be cooking for
10-15 minutes so
it's not all that fuel if it feels
inefficient
so once the stone's hot sometimes that's
the time to do pizza party if you want
to do five or six pizzas if you got
that's the time to do it you know yeah
because
most of the energy was in heat in that
stone okay
another way to do it now that's that's
the best way to do it at home i'm not
going to talk about cooking on wire
racks that's something that
you know like in a big high volume
restaurant
pizza pizzeria wire rack is another way
to do it but we're not going to talk
about it
for the home home ovens don't really get
hot enough
for that so you have to get your pizza
stone
to get the pizza on and off the stone
you're gonna need a thing called a peel
and a peel looks like a snow shovel it's
a big old flat
piece of metal with a long rod long
handle on it
and you need to develop the skills of
picking
up a rolled out round piece
of dough picking it up and getting it on
the peel and then
flinging it back off the peel there's a
bunch of tutorials and stuff online
that'll tell you how to do it
to get a dough on and off a pizza peel
and are on and off of a surface
the dough has to be
strong enough to work with and hold
together
but it can't be wet and sticky
yeah everything has to be floured
everything has to be floured and you
have to have corn meal
as a lubricant to get things off and on
the peel
okay if you can't develop these kinds of
skills of working with a peel
and a stone and high temperature and how
to make
dough and deal with dough with your
hands your only other option is a cast
iron pan
and making a pan pizza which that's in
the book too
so if you don't have these [ __ ]
equipment that i'm talking about
which is it's an investment if you don't
have the peel and the stone
you're gonna have to get you a cast iron
pan which that's not cheap either
a good cast iron pans over a hundred
dollars okay
in that one you put the dough in the pan
you push it all out you might have some
cornmeal and oil in the bottom of the
pan so it doesn't stick you make sure
it's the right thing then you start
putting your sauce and your toppings and
your cheese
yeah you're making like a deep dish yeah
and you put that in now the temperature
isn't as high on that
probably about 450 cooking times a
little bit more maybe about 15
somewhere between 15-20 minutes and
that'll give you depending on how much
you get on how much is it the more
toppings on the pizza the more
the more the cooking time okay now
the enemy of pizza is water
all right the pizza kit the
sauce has to be a tomato sauce that's
reduced
slightly to have as little water in it
as possible
okay the toppings have to have as little
water in them as possible
one of the big culprits is um mushrooms
fresh mushrooms when they cook release
water that water will be released on the
pizza
if you have a whole bunch of mushrooms
on that pizza it'll swamp
it'll release that water and it'll just
get pizza soup in there
now if the cooking temperature is real
high that may not be a problem it's just
that when the pizza comes out of the
oven
you can lay it down on your on your
pizza pan
you're going to cut on and just take
some paper towel and dry and let it
drop on top of the pizza and just press
down with your fingers and absorb all
that water don't serve it like that
absorb the water off the top of the
pizza and
and usually it'll turn out okay and then
you cut it and serve it so don't serve a
[ __ ] pizza with a bunch of
water on top a lot of times though if
we're doing putting if we're putting a
lot of mushrooms on there sometimes we
saute them yeah that's always good next
step if you're going to have like a
mushroom pizza and you want to load it
with a bunch of mushrooms
don't put raw mushrooms on the pizza and
cook it okay it'll swamp
all right uh what you do is just melt
some butter in a pan and saute those
on those those mushrooms and they'll
release the water in terms of
it's water vapors they'll dry a little
bit so get the water out
and then put it on the pizzas on top and
so pre-cooked toppings
on any pizza are more forgiving
yeah especially especially watery right
like watery vegetables and stuff
as you add toppings to a pizza getting
it on and off the peel onto the stone
becomes more and more difficult because
when you're putting the peel into the
oven and you're using
english to [ __ ] slide that pizza off
you got to snap it
snap it snap it snap it and then pull
back all right you'll you'll see people
doing it
this whole tutorial is how to do it if
there's a bunch of toppings they go
flying off the [ __ ] pizza
down the back of the oven and [ __ ]
start smoking and burning we speak from
experience
[Laughter]
so another way to do it is you have the
stone on the rack and it's [ __ ] hot
it's been in there forever
all right just throw
a dough that has
sauce and a little bit of cheese on it
onto the pizza that's easy to deal with
close it let it cook for a few sec for a
few minutes
open the oven back up pull it out top it
yeah and then throw the rack back in
there and then shut it that way
you didn't try to get that pizza onto
that stone with all those toppings on
there
topped it after it was already in place
that's a safe way of doing it because
man
one time we made this pizza and we
weren't really thinking about that and
it had like chunks of chicken on it had
artichoke hearts on it
it had like all this stuff and we were
trying to like put it on the
on the stone like [ __ ] kept falling off
in the bottom of the oven that
was smoking yeah well what happened is i
tried to sling a fully loaded pizza onto
the [ __ ] stone
yeah like that and it all the toppings
just went off the [ __ ] back yeah we
tried to be honest
and all those [ __ ] expensive top is
just being ruined and [ __ ] and falling
down onto the bottom of the [ __ ]
stove cut off a smoke alarm
and all i had to do i wasn't really
thinking all i had to do was just put a
damn cheese pizza on there
yeah let it cook for a few seconds then
top it and then put it yeah because then
you can just pull out the wrap with your
correct you know with your uh
your little as you add more toppings to
that
pizza too it's heavier so it's pushing
down on the dough
which can mean sometimes it'll push
through
the little layer of cornmeal or flour
that you have on the peel
and water will go and it'll stick to
your stone to your surf
okay i'm working on an island a kitchen
island yeah which is like a marble
table top countertop in the center of my
kitchen
and i'm making it on the [ __ ] counter
you make a pizza on a counter not on a
pan or anything like that
so your counter's got to be clean and
you want it to be as hard as possible
something like
you could do it on linoleum but you're
not really supposed to it's kind of
the linoleum can be caught up what do
you call it
porous yeah you ideally you want it to
be stone
yeah like granite like granite or marble
yeah
because there there's no porousness so
things go on and off it real well
and you can sanitize it so your
your kitchen table tops are your
surface that you're working with all
right now
step one to all that's the some of the
general rules i think i pretty much
covered it
the biggest challenge to making
the pizza the components to making the
pizza
making tomato sauce and sauce is not
that difficult that's the same as
any kind pizza sauce is there's a lot of
recipes for it online it's pretty much
the same
spaghetti sauce it's just there's less
water in it okay it's you could either
reduce it down
you can take pizza sauce and reduce it
down
okay in other words just boil it and
relieve some of the water get some of
the water out of it
okay make it a little thicker and
pastier
um but you know we're not talking about
totally pasty just
thin you know not not as thin as
spaghetti
not as thin as potato a little bit
thicker than that right you're trying to
get water away from
dough yeah and crust all right you don't
want because what
the when you put sauce on top of a raw
dough and then you start cooking it
there's a
there's a few seconds there where the
water from the sauce
seeps into the dough and when it cooks
it gives a layer of gumminess
between the crust and the sauce there'll
be like a strip of gum
you don't want that you want that to be
as minimal as possible
there's a bunch of different ways to get
to to trick that
you can just put a dough with nothing on
it just
dough in there and cook it for a few
seconds yeah some people do that and
then
and that'll that'll kind of harden the
top surface pull it back out
then top it with the sauce and the
cheese and put it back in
that's another way to do it that's to
prevent that gummy strip
all right uh the hardest
component to make is the dough a lot of
people are very uncomfortable working
with dough
all right i'm gonna get the dough in a
second let me read the uh let's read the
comments
see what's good everybody's saying yeah
and another thing too is because tila
kind of brought this up but
pizza sauce um a lot of it is
because some people like tangier sauce
some people like slightly sweeter sauce
like i kind of like a little bit sweeter
um you know but some people like kind of
tangier i can't really have real tangy
pizza sauce excuse me heartburn
but it's like so you have to really kind
of get into a thing where
you have to keep taste in it really to
get that balance that you want like
between the sweetness and the
yeah and the uh tanginess yeah all right
now tea is saying she likes thin crust
all right see
if you like a real thin crust and you
don't have a lot i'm going to teach you
a secret
you want a thin crust but you don't have
a whole lot of time
to make dough you can cheat
and make a pizza on a mexican flour
tortilla yeah we've done that
as long as you have a stone it'll be
ultra thin and ultra crispy kind of like
a cracker
like almost like a cracker and that was
real similar
to what to what pizza hut used to use
that yeah was that damn basically a big
old tortilla
yeah we made them on tortillas we've
made them on uh non-bread
yeah which that works too you still need
a stone yeah to get the texture right
you can't cook it on a metal
pan if you're [ __ ] around with metal
pants you're just jerking yourself off
[Laughter]
it's a huge difference all right um
now the secret if you're going to try to
cheat and cook on a [ __ ] tortilla
which is the one of the best cheats
really
or or on a piece of non-bread that that
works dude
all right it's nowhere near as good as
[ __ ] homemade or handmade crust but
for instant crust i'd rather do that
than buy one of those [ __ ] digiorno
[ __ ] packaged crusts in the pit nah
[ __ ] that that's a waste of money
just [ __ ] get a goddamn [ __ ]
tortilla
if you're gonna use a tortilla you can't
put a lot of toppings on it
well yeah you can't put a whole lot of
uh you can't put a whole lot of sauce on
it
because it'll kind of it'll overpower
the crust in a way you'll see if you
ever try it
it just makes a [ __ ] real fast cheap
quick to make pizza thin crust pizza
all right making dough
there's making dough making dough
the first thing when making pizza dough
is you have to overcome your fear of
[ __ ] with dough
okay you're gonna be using your hands
all right and you have to get it out of
your mind that you that you shouldn't
touch food no your hands are clean
you're working well hopefully your hands
are [ __ ] since you've been washing
your hands
you're gonna touch the dough all right
there's one
two things you absolutely need where's
three okay
everything in this [ __ ] dough that
i'm telling you about it has to be
exactly the same always
you need to get this you need to get
some dry yeast
you can get these you need yeast all
right
and it's better just to buy them in
these big [ __ ] containers
yeah you can make bread and do all kinds
of stuff with with
these yeasts like this any yeast after
the yeast is open
okay this is just in a in like a foil
bag
pour the rest of the yeast into a jar or
something that's clean
close it and put it in the refrigerator
door keep it keep the
keep the uh yeast cold okay
you can also pour it into a ziploc bag
and put it into the don't leave it
exposed though
in your uh refrigerator all right so you
need yeast
you also need water and the water should
be filtered if you have little bread of
water filters
filter out the water okay and there's a
certain kind of bread you
or a certain kind of flour you need
[ __ ] all-purpose flour
it's never going to be right i mean it
works but it's not
and you have to know what you're doing
yeah and the ratios change
that's a very thin flour it's not real
high gluten
it's a weak flour which means that you
have to put a
use a lot of the flour flour versus the
water ratio
and even when it ferments because we're
going to do [ __ ] for fermentation
but i'm going to talk about it
in in the um in the in the cookbook
it'll never have the consistency a pizza
dough is supposed to be strong enough to
support the pizza and then by the time
you get to that crust and you pull on it
it's crisp on the outside and in the
center it's kind of chewy
it's like a chewy bread all right and
that's that's what you need
that's how you do it and the flour that
you use is heavy bread flour
that's the one you gotta have and it's
hard to find that
um actually publix carries it i used to
be able to get it in 20 pound bags but
that's sam's but for some reason i guess
it doesn't sell much so that yeah
heavy bread flour that's for making
heavy bread
all right not that [ __ ] bread no yeah
you need a big bowl
big bowl okay big metallic bowl you have
to have all this equipment you need a
spatula
or a rubber egg flipper or a rubber
spatula
you put in a cup of warm water
all right filtered water you put that in
there you put
two teaspoons or you know two
tablespoons
of sugar into that warm water to stir it
and then two tablespoons
of yeast and let it sit in there for
about 20 minutes 30 minutes and it'll
kind of foam stir it every now and then
it'll it'll start to foam it'll smell a
little bit like beer when you smell
that's ready
okay and that's a cup then you put in
um two cups of water into that
which will kind of thin it out a little
bit all right and then put about
about a tablespoon of salt in that and
stir it
what that's going to do is that's going
to kill some of that yeast off in there
and the more salt you add to it the
chewier the bread will end up being
that it kind of affects texture i've
noticed all right
once that's done slowly mix in six cups
of that
heavy bread flour into that bowl three
uh
three cups of water that you have in
there wait hold on is that three no it's
two
yeah it's three cups so six
cups two at a time put two cups in there
stir it and then two more cups stir it
two more cups stir it but by the time
you get to the end of that
last cup of dough it starts to
pull itself together it gets hard to to
fold it over but just keep folding it
and then take some olive oil and pour it
around the outside of that big old ball
of damn
dough and use that rubber spatula and go
around that bowl and
bring the oil underneath the dough and
then just roll and then the dough comes
free
of the of the of the bowl and you can
reach in there and turn it around
and you can knead it and then just let
it sit there in a warm room
or in a warm oven that's turned off
maybe you have a towel over it or
something you know
uh to keep the top of the dough from
drying out and let it
rise and and you know every half hour so
go in there knead it back down and it'll
rise back again it'll knead it back down
and then it'll rise again
and that [ __ ] will go on for three or
four hours
five hours and then
take the damn dough scoop it out of the
damn bowl with your hand and put it in a
big old ziploc bag big gallon ziploc bag
pour in some olive oil slosh it around
make it so it's free from the plastic
bag close it a little bit put it in the
refrigerator
and let it sit in there overnight keep
an eye on it it'll blow up
and then you'll try to knock some of the
air out of it but once it cools off
it'll stop rising
and it's going to sit in there ferment
overnight all right it will
if you were to cook it instantly the
texture would not be right
you want to get it at least the next day
the day after that even better well i've
just told you how to make enough doper
probably about depending on the size of
the pizza
maybe about three large pizzas
maybe like four or five medium ones or a
bunch of little small ones
so that's quite a bit of dough
now when it comes time to make a pizza
you go to your working surface which is
for me a island
i get a bowl all right now i got in my
in my pantry
i would take those 25 pound bags of
flour
and pour them into a big clean bucket
big plastic bucket with a lid on it
okay and the ones that i got the buckets
they were actually started off as cat
food buckets
they had dry cat food in them and once
the cat food went down i just sanitized
it washed it out it's just a generic
bucket okay so i pour all the bread into
the bucket
that's how you do it in a restaurant so
when you need flour you open up the top
of the bucket you take just a regular
bowl a soup bowl and scoop up some flour
and put some
it could be general at this point it can
be it could be any kind of flour because
your dough is already made
you're just going to use the flour as
like something to help lubricate the
dough
pour a little mountain maybe like a half
a cup of flour
maybe half a cup of flour if you got a
if you got this much dough
a lot of this shit's by eye and
experience if you've got a ball of dough
this big it's going to take about a half
a cup of that flour
on there you put you put the ball of
dough in half a cup of flour and you
turn the ball around it and you're gonna
actually cover that ball with flour
and then once it's totally covered
you're gonna squash down on it and take
a rolling pin and roll it out into a
circle that's the easiest way to do it
okay once it's rolled out into a circle
fold the edges over the top to make a
crust
sprinkle some what do you call it
cornmeal
on the top of it then pick it up flip it
upside down it'll take guts to do that
if you've never done it before because
you're going to stretch it you're going
to [ __ ] it all up
but you get you get the hang
of flipping the dough over if you flip
the dough over and it falls apart you
[ __ ] up the dough it should have
enough strength to do that
yeah it should be strong and stretchy
okay
once you flip it over you now got the
[ __ ] thing and then you start top to
put some put some sauce on it maybe some
cheese
pick it up with your peel like i told
you about put it on the hot stove
that that is 15 minutes you can add
toppings to it later
that's how it's done now
when you go to make your first dough and
you make your first pizzas
you're gonna [ __ ] it up you're gonna
[ __ ] it up you just cannot
me as an experienced cook
trying to make pizza i [ __ ] it up
for at least six months yeah because i
remember like you going through
a lot of the you have to learn
perfecting you have to learn
stuff i mean you get a pizza made but
you're not satisfied with it
sorry our mom's asking what i'm drinking
it's just it's iced coffee
with almond milk in it you'll get the
pizza made you're just not gonna be very
satisfied with it yeah you need all the
little skills about
handling dough aging dough how long the
dough should age
it's written down online but
reading it and understanding is very
different from
doing it with your hands and
i tried to do shortcuts at first like uh
it probably doesn't really have to be
cooked on stone yes it does
every time you cook it on metal it
[ __ ] it up [ __ ] it up
just the texture would be totally wrong
it's a pizza
but the the dough would be like stale as
a piece of cardboard it had like a
cardboard
uh texture to it that's that's the
difference
i think sometimes too if you cook it on
metal it seems like it burns it on the
bottom yeah it dries the bottom out
yeah and and it never rises properly
because it's not cooking by induction
had you done it but because there's it
there
there isn't enough mass and enough heat
um in a piece of metal you know what i
mean to to
to suck the heat out of the metal into
the dough at a high rate of speed to get
that damn
crispy outside with a chewy inside that
doesn't happen
yeah and and if you tried to cook it on
cold steel
when it was you had the thing made in
the pizza pan and put it in a hot oven
it'll be even worse
the way i told you to do it is the only
way it's done because that's the way
pizza was [ __ ] made
it was made in a kiln and they were
putting it in a hot kiln on the stone
bottom of a kill of a kill
that's how it was done yeah and that's
why it comes out that way
yeah and that's like the best way to
make it like i said you can make it
other ways and it's
it will always be okay but it's not
going to be as good
i mean it's a big difference well i got
standards they don't even come out okay
it's not even okay it's just like
unacceptable yeah because like tom
is like not if he makes something and if
everybody else like says it's good but
he doesn't think it's good he's just
like no no
it's either great or it's just [ __ ]
unacceptable there is
no mediocrity you know if it's mediocre
then it's [ __ ]
yeah okay he has very high standards
yeah
if you don't have a stone and you don't
have these [ __ ] skills like i told
you the
only your only other option is a pan
pizza
out of a cast iron pan and it must be
cast iron yeah those come out very good
too
yeah and you'll recognize that you go
yeah that's
that's like uh that's a pan pizza yeah
that's what that is
yeah it's because that cast iron can get
hot enough and actually
conduct heat properly to get that
now here now there's another problem
with pan pizza because pan pizza is
forgiving and easy to make because
you're assembling it
inside of the pan a bit you get greedy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] get greedy they start putting
too many goddamn toppings in the [ __ ]
pizza just because you can
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's still room for that
in there too
so what ends up happening is when the
moisture gets released it swamps
yeah you pull it out yeah you pull it
out it's boiling
yeah all right even
if you do that in a pan pizza
man saute the and saute the toppings get
the water out of them first
okay that'll really make a more
forgiving conditions inside the pan
pizza
all right there's a
another weird problem is that
the sauce is at the bottom okay so
in that heat the vapors from the sauce
can't really escape normally because
they've been sealed in by the cheese
so the parts of the parts of the
crust boil instead of instead of bake
you don't talk about yeah so some places
back in chicago
instead of putting the sauce at the
bottom they put the cheese at the bottom
yeah all right they put the cheese the
bottom then they put some toppings and
they put a little bit of sauce on the
top of it
yeah yeah i've seen some done like
they'll do it that way yeah and when it
cooks
the sauce does kind of seep down through
the toppings but
because there's a certain amount of time
involved
it didn't swap yeah i'm talking about
some of the moisture cooked away as it
as it kind of settled in
so you do have toppings on it when it
comes out
but you don't see all that cheese some
people will add cheese on top of that
and cook it for a couple more minutes
and you know
you know what i'm talking about towards
the end that way when you look at it you
see
cheese but there's cheese at the top and
the bottom yeah
now you're talking about some serious
[ __ ] calories well you know
more cheeses and yeah now
some people might ask about what kind of
cheese
in general when you go to your average
pizzeria what they're using is partial
skim milk mozzarella it's acceptable
just like you buy at the grocery store
but that's not ideal
ideal you want real fresh mozzarella
also known as buffalo mozzarella
it comes in a cake about this big and
it's usually pre-sliced
you just take that think the cake
okay well i've got to remember that the
cake is usually uh
vacuum packed in clear plastic sometimes
it's one cake and two cakes
yeah i think sam's has like the two
cakes i think it's 8.99 or 9.99 or
something like that for two of them
yeah so that means it's four dollars of
cheese per pizza
yeah so it's expensive but that's a
really good cheese that's the cheese
that stretches
all right when you eat it it cooks the
right way it gives a chewiness
that you only had back in the 70s and in
the early 80s
when i was kid going to pizzeria when
went to places like round table pizza
and stuff
even even um pizza hut they were using
lots of buffalo mozzarella cheese it
gave that nice
stretch and chewiness to it but then
they cheapened it they used
partial skim milk mozzarella it's a big
difference but
it's okay once do not
[ __ ] put expensive cheese
on a pizza you know you're gonna [ __ ] up
and you're gonna be [ __ ] up
you're gonna be [ __ ] up you're gonna
[ __ ] up until you figure this out
so use partial skim milk until you get
good at it don't [ __ ] waste good
good uh ingredients on something you
haven't mastered yet
that's my that's my advice there um when
you're dealing with the
with a cake of mozzarella it's
pre-sliced
don't worry about grating it just pull
the thing apart in the slices and break
the slices into pieces and put on top of
the
pizza when it melts it gets very liquidy
so it spreads out pretty well but then
as soon as it starts to cool it starts
to
coagulate and become chewy it's got the
best flavor
yeah yeah and i was going to say too
that if you want to get
kind of creative with it we've done
pizzas with
different kinds of cheese too um we made
we've made one with cream cheese on it
uh which was good
we've made one with um did we make one
with goat cheese or
blue cheese or um something
i don't remember i think we didn't use a
bunch of different kinds of cheeses i've
used even even um
philadelphia cream cheese yeah certain
kinds of pizzas
it works it never browns uh it does give
a different dynamic that's
see there's also things called white
pizzas and white pizzas don't have
tomato sauce yeah it's just i love white
peas it's usually so
yeah i make a lot of those too so it
would be like a white pizza with
nothing but like olive oil that's been
you know with garlic and uh spices
and then uh you put fresh basil
on it um sauteed onions
maybe uh some special
sauteed chicken breast toppings that i
was using that's another that that's
that's another subject in itself
and then um sliced tomatoes
yeah i like non-dried i like a white
pizza with like slices of tomatoes and
then a bunch of spinach
and spinach bunch of spinach that's been
mixed up with different kinds of cheese
like
mozzarella cheese with with and then you
use little bits of philadelphia cream
cheese it's like an additional topping
now amanda i think amanda said don't use
mozzarella with your pizza don't use
buffalo mozzarella fresh mozzarella yeah
i
i've used it not not fresh mozzarella
that i've made but i've used it
if it made your pizza soggy maybe
because you're cooking um
temperature wasn't right it should melt
like all the rest of them it should get
pretty melty but then when it cools it
re-solidifies
and uh mozzarellas can brown
uh some cheeses don't brown but
mozzarellas do
uh but as far as the the the buffalo
mozzarella cakes that you can buy you
use those they're good
yeah it works yeah we've used it before
yeah i mean usually we get the partial
skim just because it's
it's cheaper you can make more pizzas
yeah yeah but i mean
i always prefer the little cakes that
you get like at sam's or costco
but it's just so expensive that we don't
like you said you make yeah it's four
dollars in chi
just in cheese on a pizza yeah that's
only two pizzas worth of cheese there
and that's like you know ten bucks
once you have all your skills
to make your own make all your skills
and everything you need to make pizzas
paid for and out of the way
you're making your own doughs and you're
making your own sauces and stuff
you're like your own pizza sauce um
you i can get the price of a large pizza
down to probably about a dollar
yeah i mean depending where you put on
it but yeah i mean it's a big initial
investment for all the stuff like the
stone and the peel and all that kind of
stuff but
once you get it all figured out like the
ingredients for it are actually pretty
cheap unless you're putting fancy ass
[ __ ] on
that's the reason why pizza pizzeria and
pizzas are so um
they're so successful in the united
states is because it's high profit
yeah if it's done right yeah you can
make a large pizza for about a dollar
yeah for [ __ ] 10. yeah yeah that's a
big markup you know what i mean i mean
obviously like you look at people like
little caesars and [ __ ] like that they
sell those [ __ ] pizzas for five
dollars you know what i mean
if you pick them up but um i wanted to
say something too i'm not sure if like
people that aren't from the u.s but
what one of the big things about
american pizza
is particularly the rivalry between new
york style pizza
and chicago style pizza now other places
have other kinds of
pizzas too like i think like [ __ ] st
louie has its own kind of pizza it's
like
you know everywhere had their own kind
of pizza but the big thing is like
because chicago
they do more of like a deep dish kind of
[ __ ]
um so sometimes like new yorkers will
say that's not a pizza it's a casserole
or you know something like that whereas
new york they tend to do not real
thin thin crust but like kind of a
floppy foldable
yeah piece yeah dario's taught
mentioning that too
he's talking about what what he likes he
what he likes in pizza
yeah pizza there's there's different
types of pizza different regional
versions chicago
new york pizza there's a lot of rivalry
between the types of pizza
but really what makes pizza unique
or what makes a pizza unique or what
makes a pizza very good
is the damn texture and most of the [ __ ]
that i'm trying to tell you it doesn't
have anything to do with flavor
it's about texture if the texture is
wrong
the pizza will be [ __ ] yeah pizza is all
texture
yeah and that's what i learned from by
trial and error
you could have the best [ __ ]
ingredients the best [ __ ]
and if it's wrong it tastes like [ __ ]
not because of the taste or the
ingredients it's because the [ __ ]
texture is wrong
yeah and i mean the thing about it i was
gonna say that it's like
uh you know deep dish thin crust regular
crust
um it's all good i i don't really have a
preference
it just kind of depends on whatever mood
i'm in that day sometimes i'm like oh
deep dish sounds good sometimes thin
crust sounds good
you know some and like i said i'll eat
pretty much any toppings i can't eat
pepperoni anymore because like i said
heartburn but um
and uh i tend i tend to like
um more on the veggie side
i you know i like meat on there i like
hamburger on there but i don't like real
spicy
meats on there um you know so i tend
more toward
you know onions mushrooms
tomatoes like big hunks of tomato stuff
like that
spinach is good on there like i said the
white pizza actually there's a pizza
place right around the corner from
uh eye bar and uh that's open all the
time
as far as i know and um they actually do
a really nice white pizza with chunks of
tomato and spinach on it
that's actually pretty decent so let me
go over again real quick the rules
water is the enemy of pizza at all
stages at all stages of production
good
pizza must be cooked on a stone or cast
iron it just has to
cooking temperature is as high as
possible cooking time is as low
as possible the best new york pizza
started at lombardi's
it's a place down in new york and
evidently it's not it's not it ain't
[ __ ] compared to
what it was back in the day but new york
pizza and pizza in general
in the united states was born in
lombardies and the
lombardi the reason why lombardi's was a
pizzeria is because it was a kiln
before it was a restaurant and they were
in there they were doing something with
porcelain
i think they just made porcelain pots
and [ __ ] and then it changed hands
became a pizzeria some italians took it
over
and they introduced pizza now it wasn't
exactly the same pizza that you know but
it was that same dough in that same type
of crust
and that that oven was like a thousand
degrees at all times it never cooled
down it burned all the way throughout
the night it wasn't even worth it to
[ __ ] let the oven cool off it took
too long
so they just kept that coal fire going
for like a hundred years
never [ __ ] they never they never put
it out never put it out
okay and uh i think the cooking time
on one of their pizzas was like some
amazingly low like
three or four minutes yeah and when it
came out it was
crispy and chewy and had burnt high
high spots on it and it was just that
was like the perfect
new york pizza it was not the pizza
that you really know today i mean they
weren't even really round they were more
like
oval because they threw them in there so
fast yeah
um they had different kind of topics it
was more like focaccia in a certain way
it might have olive oil on it and some
tomatoes which is more like it was back
in italy yeah
and then maybe they added a piece of
cheese later there was red white and
green on them
and that was because that was the colors
of the italian flag yeah it's that
simple
you know that's why i did it yeah
and for it spread from there italian
gangsters made it famous
a lot of people don't know al capone had
a lot to do with success of pizza yep
yeah
al capone likes chicago pizza
which is kind of like what you would
call as a hand-tossed pizza and it or a
deep dish
which is like a cat it's a cast iron pan
yeah yeah all right
you didn't need a sophisticated oven to
do that all right
when al capone became kind of like a
criminal superstar
they couldn't get anything pinned on him
he hunt he hung out
in bars that sold
pasta pizza
chicago deep dish pizza and um
booze but they they sold the booze
illegally
but they were selling it there but he
would hang out there and have
meetings and people come see him and the
newspapers came in there one day
and said that he was eating an exotic
italian dish called pizza and they asked
him about it
and he said you know i don't remember
exactly what it was but he what he said
but paraphrasing he said it was the
perfect
food because you could eat it for
breakfast lunch or dinner and it was an
entire meal just
all in in one pan he was ahead of his
time he was ahead of his time
well because he said that everybody
wanted to know what this [ __ ] strange
italian dish that these [ __ ] famous
gangsters
were eating and that made pizza famous
which is hilarious when you think about
it yeah just like one famous dude that
was like
well it's hilarious to us now because
pizza seems like such a quote-unquote
american food because everybody [ __ ]
eats it not in those days
but yeah back in those days well [ __ ]
man like i said we've talked about this
before but we've had like really old
like recipe books
where spaghetti and meatballs and stuff
like that was seen as like some exotic
foreign food
and they had to explain to you what
oregano was right
and they would say oregano is like a
very exotic italian
uh you know herb and you you can get it
in certain specialty stores and [ __ ]
and what was funny is that that would be
the only herb in it
yeah salt pepper i think a little uh
salt pepper and oregano that's what was
in the tomato sauce
just that which i can't imagine that i
mean that has been like super bland
yeah real bland which it didn't even
you know but i think things were kind of
bland then they were i guess
well at least here like i said until
until all the good people immigrated and
were kind of like hey here's some good
food with spices in it
get your food together i really don't
think that's what it was what i think
that was was availability
that too yeah they didn't have they
didn't have a distribution center for
any of that
so because they couldn't just they
couldn't distribute it
people didn't know about it yeah and
because they didn't know about it they
didn't request it there was no market
for it
it wasn't until people were exposed to
things
or you had companies that had the
ability to deliver things to the far
reaches of the united states
and they had good things to sell so they
had to let people know about them
yeah one one of the ones i'm thinking
about would have been would have been
heinz
the heinz company was one of the first
like real
mass marketing companies they
had direct salesmen that went to all
these little mom paw stores and all
these little
um what do you call them like uh general
stores
and they would introduce themselves to
the store owner and they said
you know we're a food company and if you
agree to work with us
we'll come in and we'll bring
a shelf aisle a special aisle
for our products and and our products
only
and you'll get a cut of the profits and
we'll deliver it we'll handle all the
stock don't worry about it
you just sit back ring up the cash
register and you'll make money
so heinz was really the first big
corporation
that on a nationwide level tried to to
distribute
food everywhere and the reason why they
were able to do this is pre-refrigera
refrigeration and they were able to do
it because all their stuff was basically
pickled
yeah it was pickled and jarred and some
of it was canned
and it was meat and vegetables
both but but what was weird is that
their
definition of what a vegetable was was
would not be
recognizable by you
ketchup was a vegetable yeah
mayonnaise was like a meat
[Laughter]
and [ __ ] mustard was a vegetable
and pickles were a vegetable well i mean
that
started out as a vegetable
and that all sounds familiar because
that's your condiments
yeah and in the 1800s those were
considered to be vegetables
yeah that was some high-tech [ __ ] it was
like
pureed vegetables that you didn't need
to
refrigerate that would last for a long
time stuff that had
eggs in it and you could put it on meat
which eventually gave birth to the
hamburger yeah which is also considered
to be foreign at the time
which a lot of people don't know that
hamburgers were not considered to be
american when they
when they appeared they were considered
to be kind of german
because it was hamburg beef yeah they
were from hamburg
ground beef in a damn
dinner roll with some pickles and some
sauteed onions
and some vegetables from hunts or heinz
which meant
ketchup mustard mayonnaise and it was a
company called white cast
that was the first hamburger what was
funny people think they were
mcdonald's or or no hamburgers were
something that were made at home it was
traditional no hamburgers came from
white [ __ ] castle
all right and they had to hire doctors
to stand outside and tell people that
they were safe to eat
people like they wouldn't eat that [ __ ]
and they put them outside
factories so the factory workers and
they would
you know they would they had a whole
campaign to convince factory workers
that this was safe nutritious food that
had meat and vegetables and bread
all in all in a single meal and you
could afford to eat it
and you could carry it in one hand and
carry it well now they always sold them
in a six pack
yeah they were in this all because we
have that too but it's crystal yeah
ours are called crystal or the k yeah
so uh yeah now we're getting off the
subject of pizza though
yeah we'll have to do a whole burger
episode one of these days
but yeah so uh was there anything else
you needed to say about pizza you you
went like pretty in depth into like how
to make darius it hurts somewhere in the
south they deep fried pizza but they
would deep fry anything in this out man
yeah
i've never seen it but it wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me yeah but
he fried ice cream deep fried mars bars
they do that in scotland yeah yeah fried
mars bars yeah that actually kind of
sounds good well deep-fried anything
sounds pretty good
gotta say it but um yeah i even like a
corn dog every now and then
okay are there any guys have any
questions about dough or anything about
pizza
you can put it in the comments section
yeah oh tea says man or stomach
grumbling for pizza
[Laughter]
at least i'm but it's good that we you
know eat before we do the show so then
i'm
like sitting there making myself hungry
like i said we didn't have pizza today
we had brisket
we're talking about anchovies on pizza i
never liked it
yeah i'm not a fan i really i like um i
like fish in general
but anchovies it's just too much i'm not
hating on you if you do like that but
it's just
i don't know i'll eat like i said pretty
much any kind of pizza topping
but anchovies ah
what's a shame is that rather not what's
a shame is that the era
of the big ma and paw
family owned pizzeria seems to be gone i
don't know why
i guess it's a lost skill maybe it's not
energy efficient you can't get enough
people to go in and out of there
could be that pizza has kind of a low
end um kind of a low end image nowadays
like oh
why would i go in there and spend all
this money when i can get that at
you know in five minutes coming up pizza
hut you know it might be something like
that but
some of the mom pop pizzerias that i
grew up with in california men were
fantastic
and you'll never you'll never really be
able to buy those again you have to
[ __ ] make that at home
and you really got to know what you're
doing to replicate how good
pizza used to be it's not as good as it
was
it used to be much better although the
thing about it is that i think if you
want like really good pizza out
you're gonna have to go to like sort of
a boutique yeah
you know kind of fancy pizza place that
actually makes everything from scratch
yeah although sometimes that sucks too
like pizzeria uno would be considered
that and i hate their pizza
i liked their shrimp pizza they had like
a shrimp pizza that was not too bad but
that was a long time ago that i ate that
the best chain pizza i remember from
back in the day
was old school old school
um uh round table pizza was really good
you got in california the old school
original california chuck e cheese
and that was a location out in
california it was an arcade
they had a pizzeria in there that was
fantastic that's not what they're
serving
on the nationwide level but well no the
original one
oh man yeah that was good really good
uh there was a really good uh
mom paw italian place called fioritos
i think it was might have been in long
beach or in that area i don't know if it
exists anymore
probably not probably not but that place
was [ __ ]
amazing and that was real italians
working in there and uh
the entire wall to the kitchen was gl
was plexiglas so you could see what they
were doing in there and it was like 10
dudes just making pizzas
and places always packed [ __ ]
beautiful pizza
and um the only other pizzas ever close
to those old school [ __ ]
or that i get nowadays are are the ones
i make yeah
because i'm kind of doing it similar the
way there are still certain things that
they did that i don't know how the [ __ ]
they did i could remember what it tasted
like
i can remember how it smelled i can't
really quite replicate it
um they did it differently they made
really big pizzas which tells me that
they had a huge peel
and they had a big old [ __ ] oven we
cut
we cut slices you know what i'm talking
about like yeah
like triangular slices they didn't do
that they cut it in a grid
some people some places still do that
yeah they're like square pieces in the
middle and stuff they cut it in a grid
um as far as chains go right now
probably if you're talking about
corporate chains the best pizza places
right now
probably be like papa john's although
some people hate
papa john's i like i think it's the best
one i like their sauce the best i mean
uh
it's like none of them are fantastic but
if you just want a pizza quick it's like
delivered to your house
i've picked that one yeah they're all
decent i think i like papa john's sauce
the best
yeah i like all of their i just like the
pizza in general the best
yeah it's better than pete uh better
than a lot better okay
pizza hut is fast and you know exactly
what it is that's common but it's super
super generic
yeah it's nowhere near as good as it was
when i was a kid when i was a kid pizza
hut was [ __ ] awesome it was good well
it was a sit down right now
it was expensive you went in there and
there was like a jukebox and you get a
big picture of beer and like
yeah it was good and you walked in there
and just smelled the place t probably
remembers
because i was out in california out in
california when you sat down there and
that place [ __ ] smelled great
but it started to decline it started to
become
kind of more like a buff like a buffet
you could pay all you could eat and
they'd have [ __ ] pizzas out in that
in the middle of the thing and then it
started to go the way of like cece's
well yeah cece's isn't that a buffet
yeah and then they kind of rebooted it
went no no no
we're we're like the italian burger king
that's what it became now
like burger king the burger king of
pizza
yeah it's just everything's just you
know quick and cheap
which like i said if you don't feel like
making a pizza because you know it is a
time commitment obviously like making a
pizza you gotta make the dough a couple
days ahead
you gotta make the sauce which has to
cook for a while and stuff like that so
i can understand just ordering it and we
do it every now and then
um but it's just never as good as the
ones you make and like i said i still
i still fondly remember when i was a kid
getting pizza from pantheon getting that
hamburger and onion pizza and again it
was a big it was like
like that big and it was uh not like i
said this but the meat wasn't real spicy
but it was just like a big it had a
really really nice crust on it it was
just like a really nice flavor
yeah and i don't even know if that
[ __ ] place is there anymore t's in
there tripping out over to british
people
[Laughter]
man goes in here talking about putting
big beans on pizza [ __ ] teeth going
big beans on pizza y'all crazy yeah man
i over there so they're not the only
ones that are crazy though because
the japanese also put corners brazilians
brazilians do [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] with
pizza too they don't really know what
they're doing
and at least but whatever shut up
priscilla pizza is almost steamed
it's like [ __ ] at least it used to be
you know
your real common ones they didn't have a
crisp crust just like a doughy
[ __ ] and they'd have [ __ ]
chickpeas on the damn pizza and [ __ ]
green
green uh peas on the damn
and um hearts of palms sliced hearts of
palm
just cheap [ __ ] that brazilians have in
cans you know they put that on the pizza
it tastes like [ __ ] but they did have
some places that could execute good
pizza
they didn't have pepperoni though they
had something called calabresa which is
like pepperoni
kinda not quite as spicy uh so
we should we used to get that calabrese
a pizza and it was like close to like a
slice of
kind of like new york pepperoni pizza
kind of
the texture was correct that's the
reason why i liked it
it did not taste like pepperoni though
similar but
you could tell the difference yeah yeah
it was more kind of like uh
cured ham which then that's wrong
yeah but not i don't remember it as
being a sausage though
yeah it was like a cured ham well like i
said you can get you know you can get
like hawaiian quote-unquote pizza here
that has like chunks of ham and
pineapple on it and you know nothing
like that
amanda said last time i ordered pizza
hut my dog ate the pizza and i ate the
breadsticks
[Laughter]
the thing about p i kind of feel like i
don't know what it is i think pizza
puts too much [ __ ] on the pizza there's
just too much [ __ ] on there you know
what i mean it's just it's too heavy
i don't know it depends on what you get
that's true
i mean you know i mean like i said i'm
not going to turn it down if you're free
but yeah they'll put whatever you want
to put on a damn pizza you know
i well when i like p i like pizza with
like a thin layer of sauce and a bunch
of cheese
i don't like a bunch of soupy sauce on
there yeah i just like a little bit of
sauce and a bunch of cheese
yeah that's another thing is that when
you're new to making pizza you have a
tendency to like i said before getting
[ __ ] greedy i'll put more oh
i put more it'll be even better now less
is more on a pizza always
yeah i mean kind of keep it simple
there's a there's a maximum amount of
[ __ ] you can put on a pizza once you
reach a certain amount you can't put any
more it just starts to get worse
so if you're gonna make something like a
supreme pizza that has a whole lot of
stuff on it
a whole lot of different things there
can't be very much of each one
and it kind of goes against your
intuition like that's not over and
that's not a lot of [ __ ] olives
well that'll be a lot of olives once you
put it up once you realize how much all
those other toppings you got
once you put 40 000 yeah it's gonna all
add up
you know so yeah
that's the kind of like i kind of like
to stay away from
supreme type pizzas yeah i'm not a big
fan it's like really i don't like i like
you know
a couple of toppings yeah three two two
or three tops
right more toppings than that you're
just like you're asking for trouble
because you're gonna have an olive but
only have like maybe
one all of a slice because there has to
be a couple of pepperonis on it
and then it has to be a couple little
pieces of onion
and then there has to be like a couple
little pieces of something or other
so the next thing you know there there's
a lot of different stuff on each slice
but not a lot of it you know what i'm
talking about yeah
and i feel like the more [ __ ] you put on
there it's like you can't really taste
any of the individual components right
there has to be there's like one little
olive on your slice
yeah but if you had 20 on there then the
whole thing would soup out
yeah yeah i mean frankly like when you
make pizza
for me i'm just kind of like i like
mushroom and
maybe some bell pepper yeah on it and
then that's about it
yeah i mean it's good like that you can
taste all the individual components
no another thing i forgot to say is that
pepperoni on on a home pizza
if you you can go down to publix and get
a little package of the pre-sliced
pepperoni at pretty much any of these
grocery stores but if you have a sam's
account or costco or costco you get a
much better deal you can get
you can get a package of two big bags
this big for like about eight bucks
and that's really only the price of a
couple of the little small ones
and you take that you can put that in
the freezer it'll freeze indefinitely
you can top the pizza with that make a
[ __ ] ton of pizza so i was saying you
know my pizzas only end up maybe about a
dollar
like a dollar worth of stuff on it yeah
that's it
because you buy everything in bulk
that's why you want to get yeast in bulk
you don't want those little ones because
this is only a couple bucks yeah
yeah that'll make that'll make a lot of
stuff well [ __ ] yeah because to make the
dough
to make enough dough for like two or
three big pizzas you only need what like
a couple
tablespoons of that right so yeah it
lasts a long time
yeah all right so uh you don't talk
about pizza puppies
see you've been going at somebody in the
comments said yeah on the show yesterday
and said you found your calling because
it's like you actually stayed on one
single topic
for more than an hour which you did
today too yeah talking about food and
see
and i'm sleepy too and you're sleepy too
you did good
see
[Laughter]
not only did i bring all this [ __ ] back
but i got like the [ __ ] testosterone
levels of [ __ ] three three [ __ ]
fifteen-year-old boys oh now it's three
i thought i got three yesterday
every time i talk about it there's more
of them more of them in there
there was a [ __ ] side effect i forgot
about
when you start going backwards in time
to become a child again
not only not only do you start [ __ ]
stinking and [ __ ] your stocks start
stinking like
you're a little kid but also
you run real hard you start aging in dog
years where you're [ __ ]
sweating all the time you know like that
but then all of a sudden you want to
sleep all day
yeah you have energy but it
it was back when i was a teenager have
all this energy and then all of a sudden
i'm gonna sleep honestly yeah you can
see yeah they're like teenage boys and
they'll like
sleep for like [ __ ] 12 hours yeah
sleep for 12 hours
it kind of seems to be happening in a
cycle yeah
so every time it's bad because it's like
every time it's like afternoon it's time
to live stream or record some stuff and
he's just always kind of like
yeah i already [ __ ] you know went on
a [ __ ] two mile hike and [ __ ]
hey i did a three mile hike with it with
i think i lift tomorrow i feel like i'm
growing growth
growth growth yeah somebody said yeast
equals growth
yeah that's right we're going to
sprinkle some sleep
right now well you can go take a nap now
because you you did good we recorded a
movie review today
and you did like an hour long thing on
the thing yeah you know you did good you
can
you can go take a nap you earned it oh
yeah
[ __ ] that's funny all right so uh we'll
be back tomorrow probably tomorrow we'll
uh do a movie review because i can find
a new movie tonight we talk about that
because like i said i don't want to wear
out all the food topics
even though these are fun to do i
actually do but i don't want to get too
much out of the
movie thing too but uh yeah so we'll
watch a new one tonight we can do that
um tomorrow
so thanks everybody for dropping by
listening to us talking about pizza
yeah and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow
bye